stormy Daniels who's now in under news
everywhere she is in three of your
movies thank you yeah yeah yeah she has
bit parts and most but she has a major
role in the movie you did the stormy
Daniels story oh so she's in your movies
did you get to know her at all or what
if there's a sex tape and you find out I
directed it she's very nice and super
smart and great to work with so we just
kept asking her to be in all of our
movies maybe because we were scared to
meet other adult film star especially
since several but I know I'm just
disturbed by the whole thing
all the sex stuff with Trump and you
know cuz it all started with the Access
Hollywood tape and then you know the
only Bush there yeah so like you know
it's locker room talk you know it's
locker room talk which I always thought
was so wrong because I've never been in
a locker room no one talks yeah it's a
weird it's not it's this lot there's a
lot of Chatty Cathy especially talking
about sex yeah but you guys stand around
naked talking about sex I mean if I was
in a locker room and it was naked and
someone walked up to me and said you
like to grab the whoa
to furniture you know you move on like a
[ __ ] you know Akram is trying figure
out how to change in a way where part of
my clothing is always covering my penis
you can get in though I get in the
locker change and then get out this I'm
a master at that
you